R
HEART BE TROUBLED.
WE'LL SEE YOU BACK HERE TOMORROW
NIGHT, LAURA IS NEXT.
>> Laura: I'M LAURA INGRAHAM
AND THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
FROM WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
NO STATE LEFT BEHIND IS THE
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."
>> WERE ASKING YOU TO THINK LONG
AND HARD ABOUT THE MOMENT THAT
YOU'RE IN.
IN A TYPICAL YEAR, WERE OFTEN
NOT FACED WITH QUESTIONS OF
WHETHER THE VOTE WE CAST WILL
PRESERVE DEMOCRACY OR PUT US AT
RISK.
BUT THIS YEAR, WE ARE.
>> Laura: DISSECTING BIDEN
SPEECH ON DEMOCRACY, IT'S NOT ON
MY TIME OR YOURS.
THE RIOT ON JANUARY 6 WAS
DANGEROUS AND TRAGIC.
BUT AMERICANS ARE SMART ENOUGH
TO UNDERSTAND THE REAL THREATS
TO DEMOCRACY ARE COMING FROM THE
LEFT.
WITHOUT HER FIRST AMENDMENT, ART
OF THOUGHT STOMACH DEMOCRACY IS
LIKELY TO SURVIVE.
WE KNOW NOW THAT BIDEN AND HIS
INTEL SERVICES CONSPIRED WITH
BIG TECH TO CENSOR OPPOSING
POLITICAL VIEWS.
HOW IS THAT HONORING CHERISHED
NORMS?
HOW IS IT LIVING UP TO OUR
DEMOCRATIC IDEALS TO USE THE
MOST TOXIC AND MOST VICIOUS
SMEARS AS POLITICAL WEAPONS?
>> WHAT WE SEEN FROM BRIAN KEMP
IS A CONTINUATION OF 12 YEARS OF
RACIST BEHAVIOR.
>> DOMESTIC TERRORISM, ROOTED IN
WHITE SUPREMACY, IS THE GREATEST
TERRORIST THREAT TO OUR HOMELAND
TODAY.
>> INDIVIDUALS LIKE
RON DeSANTIS AND GREG ABBOTT
PEDAL IN HATRED AND XENOPHOBIA.
>> Hannity: [LAUGHS]
>> Laura: HOW ARE THEY
UPHOLDING OUR SYSTEM OF
GOVERNMENT WHEN THEY THREATEN A
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE LIKE
SCHUMER DID?
AND THEN THEY PROCLAIMED THE
ILLEGITIMACY OF THE COURT WHEN
THEY DISAGREE WITH THE DOBBS
RULING.
>> WE HAVE TO CALL OUT THE
SUPREME COURT FOR LYING TO THE
SENATE.
WE HAVE SO MANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE SUPREME COURT AND THE
LEGITIMACY.
SPEED TO HOUSE THEIR PLAN TO
PACK THE COURT OR ABOLISHED THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE GOING TO
PROTECT DEMOCRACY?
HOW EXACTLY DOES BIDEN TRAINING
OUR EMERGENCY PETROLEUM RESERVES
FOR POLITICAL GAIN QUALIFY AS
ADVANCING DEMOCRACY?
HOW'S A DEMOCRAT TO RETAIN AND
THEN ABUSE EMERGENCY POWERS LONG
AFTER THE PANDEMIC THAT IS OVER?
BIDEN MIGHT NOT HAVE HAD THAT
WEIRD RED LIGHTING BEHIND HIM AS
HE DID IN THAT BIZARRE
INDEPENDENCE HALL SPEED BACK IN
SEPTEMBER.
BUT THE REACTION FROM AMERICA
WILL BE THE SAME.
DISCUSSED IN DISBELIEF.
MR. PRESIDENT, STOP INSULTING US
WITH YOUR TONE-DEAF CYNICAL
APPEALS.
FOR ONCE, FOCUS ON THE ISSUES
THAT MATTER TO US.
UNLESS HE THINKS CNN IS PART OF
THE VAST RIGHT-WING CONSPIRACY.
HE MAY HAVE OVERLOOKED THE TOP
ISSUES THAT THEY REVEALED IN
THEIR NEW SURVEY FOR VOTERS.
AS YOU CAN SEE, NEGATIVE FUELED
THREATS TO DEMOCRACY DO NOT
RATED ALL.
WAKE UP JOE.
IT'S TIME FOR YOUR PUPPY PILLS.
THIS ALL IS PLAYING OUT EXACTLY
AS WE PREDICTED THOUGH.
>> WHEN WE LOOK AT FLORIDA, THE
COALITION THAT WROTE THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
PUT TOGETHER IN THAT STATE IS
REALLY SOMETHING THAT YOU SHOULD
TRY TO REPLICATE AS MUCH IS
POSSIBLE GOING FORWARD, UP AND
ON THE EAST COAST, WITH A STRONG
CONTINGENT OF SENIORS, LATINOS,
YOUNG PROFESSIONALS,
AFRICAN AMERICANS.
>> Laura: INDEED, GOVERNMENT
AND ARE RON DeSANTIS HAD BEEN
BRIGHT LIGHT AMID THE DARKNESS
OF THE PAST TWO YEARS.
HE'S OUT CAMPAIGNING OUT WEST
AND UP NORTH.
>> IF LEE ZELDIN GETS INTO
OFFICE, NEW YORK WILL BECOME A
LAW AND ORDER STATE AND WILL BE
A LAW AND ORDER GOVERNOR.
>> SIX MONTHS AGO, ALTHOUGH
SMART PUNDITS SET UP REPUBLICAN
CAN'T WIN IN NEW YORK AND THAT'S
WHAT THEY SAID IN VIRGINIA LAST
YEAR.
THEY FORGOT TO DO ONE THING,
THEY FORGOT TO ASK VOTERS.
>> Hannity: SURE ENOUGH,
SUBURBAN WOMEN DON'T LIKE
PROPAGANDA IN SCHOOL EITHER OR
TRANSGENDER IS IN RUINING GIRLS
SPORTS.
NOW, FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE
RONALD REAGAN RETIRED, WE HAVE
THE TYPE OF REPUBLICAN PARTY
THAT CAN ACTUALLY CHALLENGE THE
DEMOCRATS ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
WERE NO LONGER WEIGHED DOWN BY
THE BUSHES AND THEIR OBSESSIONS
WITH OPEN BORDERS AND HELPING
CHINA, ENDLESS WARS.
OUR POPULIST MESSAGES BREAKING
THROUGH ALL OF THE NATION.
>> WE ARE TAKING A STAND AGAINST
INDOCTRINATING OUR KIDS IN OUR
SCHOOLS.
YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO SEND YOUR
KID TO KINDERGARTEN WITHOUT
HAVING TRANSGENDER IDEOLOGY
INJECTED.
>> WE ARE COMMON SENSE VOTERS,
WE BELIEVE IN THE AMERICAN
DREAM.
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY HAS LEFT OF
THE HISPANIC COMMUNITY.
>> Laura: FROM NONTOP 2024,
THE EFFORT TO WIN THE COASTS HAS
TO BE THE PRIMARY FOCUS OF THE
G.O.P.
ANYONE, AND I'M TALKING ANYONE
WHO WANTS TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT,
HAS TO SHOW THAT HE OR SHE IS
WILLING AND PREPARED TO CAMPAIGN
IN PLACES LIKE NEW YORK,
NEW YORK, OUT WEST IN L.A., EVEN
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
NEW ENGLAND, AND THE UPPER
NORTHWEST AS WELL.
MANY VOTERS IN THOSE STATES
HAVEN'T HAD THE CHANCE TO ATTEND
A REAL G.O.P. PRESIDENTIAL RALLY
IN GENERATIONS AND I HAVEN'T HAD
THE CHANCE TO ORGANIZE, TO KNOCK
ON DOORS, TO GET THEIR FRIENDS
AND NEIGHBORS EXCITED ABOUT THE
MESSAGE.
BUT THAT'S CHANGING NOW.
AND THAT CHANGE MUST CONTINUE.
ALL YEAR LONG, YOU'VE MIGHT HAVE
GOTTEN SICK OF IT, BUT THE
"ANGLE" HAS EMPHASIZED A SINGLE
THEME: NO AMERICAN AND NO STATE
LEFT BEHIND.
I THINK THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY,
DO YOU NOT AGREE, FOR A
REPUBLICAN 50 STATE STRATEGY TO
WIPE THE DEMOCRATS OUT IN 2024
AND 2022, NOT JUST IN THE OLD
RED STATE BLOCKS BUT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY FROM NEW YORK TO
WASHINGTON STATE AND CALIFORNIA
AND BEYOND.
>> WE HAVE A SLOGAN AT THE
INGRAHAM ANGLE CALLED NO STATE
LEFT BEHIND.
WE ARE THRILLED WITH THE GROWTH
TAKING PLACE IN HOUSTON, MIAMI,
AND NASHVILLE.
WE LOVED THE RURAL PEOPLE WHO
WERE FIGHTING FOR POPULISM TEN
YEARS AGO AND HELPED
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN 2016 BUT WERE
NOT GONNA STOP THERE.
THERE ARE GREAT AMERICANS IN
CONNECTICUT, NEW YORK,
WASHINGTON, MAINE, AND YES, IN
CALIFORNIA, AND THEY DESERVE
GOOD GOVERNMENT TOO.
NO AMERICAN SHOULD HAS TO LIVE
IN A KIND OF TERROR WE SEE IN
NEW YORK CITY AND MINNEAPOLIS
AND SAN FRANCISCO.
THERE ARE FELLOW AMERICANS, OUR
FRIENDS AND HER FAMILY.